على كل المزيد من المتابعه معي الان من
امام مقر شركه تويتر في سان فرانسيسكو
مراسل العربيه حسين الطود حسين اهلا وسهلا
بك بالطبعا انت اقرب الى المشهد منا هنا
جديد المشهد من عند كيف يبدو جديد الاخبار
والمعلومات المتعلقه بتويتر وكيف يتابع
الامريكيون ما يجري
تحيه لك طالب يبدو ان موضوع تويتر
مع كل يوم ومع الاخبار ومع الاستقالات
التي تتزايد يوميا انا الان كما تفضلت
موجود هنا في سان فرانسيسكو قرب مبنى
تويتر الذي يظهر خلفيه طبعا همم الساعه
السابعه صباحا ما زالت هنا لهذا لا يوجد
الكثير من الماره ي- يتجولون همم
الخطوره بموضوع تويتر الطالب حسب
الاستقالات من جانب التقنيين انفسهم الذين
هم مسؤولون في الحقيقه على استمراريه همم
الموقع وعلى همم لا يكون هناك هجوم
سيفراني حضرتك قلت انه ثلاثه من اصل 75
سنه نتمشى قليلا طالما نقترب من المبنى
همم هناك ايضا همم ارقام مخيفه اكثر همم
مثلا همم في فريق خدمات الرئيسيه الذي كان
فيها 100 شخص تقريبا الان اصبح هناك فقط
اربعه اشخاص وهذا الفريق في الاصل يطالب
هو يتعامل مع هندسه الحوسبه هناك فرق اخرى
عبر العالم استقالت وهي ايضا مسؤوله عن
استمرار ال- ال- ال- الخدمات وهمم عدم
حصول اختراقات امنيه الان التخوف الكبير
اذا اذا واجه تويتر اي هجوم همم امني
سيبراني كيف سيتعامل في ظل هذا العدد
القليل نتحدث عن ربع في بعض الاوقات وعن
همم
بضعه اشخاص من اصل المئات هم الان يتكفلون
بذلك بعض المراقبين قالوا بان ال- ال-
المشكله لن تظهر ربما اليوم الان ولكنها
مع المستقبل سيبدا المستخدمون يشعرون
باولا بالثقل الاتصال بصعوبه رفع على
الفيديوهات او تنزيلها وايضا موضوع التايم
لاين الجدول الزمني ان يكون تحديثه سريعا
كما هو كما كان معتادا سابقا اخطر ما في
ذلك وهو من يقولون بانه سيكون الاختبار
الحقيقي هو يوم كاس العالم
قال بانه سيغطي كاس العالم بشكل مميز ومن
المعروف انه في وقت كاس العالم يكون هناك
عدد كبير من الزوار يدخلون الى الموقع
لمشاركه اراءهم ورؤيه الفيديوهات الموجوده
هناك الان مع مع هذا العدد القليل اقل عدد
يعني نصف اكثر من نصف لانه لانه البارحه
كان هناك استقاله تقريبا ما بين 1000 الى
11 جديد استقاله من تويتر همم هؤلاء ايضا
هم طبعا يعني احنا لا نتحدث عن 4000
تقريبا و900 موظف استقاله من تويتر من اصل
7000 و500 موظف انا مازلت هنا طالب همم
قرب هذا المبنى وهو مبنى ضخما مؤلف من
مبنيين همم ساذهب معك الى الى المدخل
الرئيسي من خلال قلت لك طالب تخوف الان من
الشق التقني اضافه الى الشرق المتعلق
بالمحتوى لانه حتى المحتوى يعني
نذكر المشاهدين لانه نحن لا نشاهد احد
لانه في ساعات الصباح الاولى يعني يعطيك
العافيه همم حسين انت سعد همم صباح الاولى
على مدخل المبنى الرئيسي تويتر
ما قاله بيتر كلوز انه الرؤيه ضبابيه جدا
داخل الشركه العاصفه قادمه لمحاله وهو
مدير في تويتر طب الاسئله وحتى اللي
بتجيني على من بعض المتابعين على تويتر
انه خطر على البيانات مصير بيانات
المستخدمين وهل هذا سيدفع السلطات
الامريكيه القضائيه الى التدخل ام لا حتى
الساعه السلطات القضائيه لن تتدخل في هذه
المساله
طالبه تعليقا على هذا الموضوع هناك سبعه
اعضاء في مجلس الشيوخ بالفعل الطالب
اللجنه الفيدراليه همم التجاريه ان تتدخل
لترى وتتحقق ما اذا كانت بيانات
المستخدمين الان حفظ على سريتها على
خصوصيتها بعد استلام لهم ماسك زمامور هذا
موضوع مطروح همم كما قلت اصلا هناك موضوع
اخر موضوع باسال كراهيه التي تقول تدافع
همم تحاربه جمعيات مدنيه وحقوقيه كثيره
هنا يقولون ان سياسات انهم ماسك اذا همم
يقول انها حريه التعبير هذه قد تبث
الكراهيه همم
تنشرها اكثر رغم ان الرجل قال البارحه
بانه لم يتم الترويش لخطاب الكراهيه وسيتم
همم
ابطال هيا تغريده ولكنه لن يمنعها من
الوجود لن يحذفها قال من يريد ان يصل الى
هذه التغريد ان يمكنه ان يصل لها ولكن لم
يتم الترويج لها انه ماسك في المقابل
ويدافع عن نفسه ولكن طبيعه حال بالنسبه
لاعضاء مجلس الشيوخ هناك تخوف من هذا
الموضوع ولم استبعد ايضا ان نرى مع تويتر
مر ايناه مع اييه انستغرام ومع فيسبوك همم
موضوع السوشيال ميديا في الولايات المتحده
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي موضوع خطير نظر
نظرا لتاثير الذي لديه على فئه كبيره من
الناس تويتر مختلف قليلا او كثيرا حتى عن
انستغرام هو لا يتوجه الى المراهقين هو
يتوجه الى القادسيه ولكنهم بانه يروج
دعايه سياسيه و يروج لحزب مقابل لهم مصر
همم هو قالها انه يؤيد الجمهوريين اكثر من
الديمقراطيين يعني هذه كلها امور بالفعل
مطروحه ويتم التعامل معها بجديه الولايات
المتحده وهذا ذلك ونلاحظه ايضا من خلال
التغطيه الاعلاميه لذلك طيب نكتفي بهذا
القدر يعطيك الف عافيه سنكون معك في
النشرات اللاحقه لمزيد من المتابعه حول
هذا الموضوع من امام مقر شركه تويتر نيسان
فرانسيسكو الامريكيه مراس العربي حسين
الطاوت شكرا جزيلا لك